Hey guys, I'm off to the supermarket to do some grocery shopping and I thought you guys would like to know what's on my list. Here we go. Ready? Yogurt, granola, tomato sauce, ketchup, dried fruit, baked beans, nut butter, chocolate milk, cereal bars, bread, condiments, salad dressings, protein bars, candy, tea, crackers, energy drinks, canned fruit, juice, coffee, soda, ice cream, barbecue sauce, and cakes. Welcome to Smart List. Smart
大家好，我正要去超市买点东西，我想你们应该会想知道我的购物清单。我们开始吧。准备好了吗？酸奶、格兰诺拉麦片、番茄酱、番茄沙司、果干、焗豆、坚果酱、巧克力奶、谷物棒、面包、调味品、沙拉酱、蛋白棒、糖果、茶、饼干、能量饮料、罐装水果、果汁、咖啡、苏打水、冰淇淋、烧烤酱和蛋糕。欢迎来到《Smart List》。Smart
List Smart List Smart List Smart List Smart
List Smart List Smart List Smart List Smart List Smart List Smart I had a great day yesterday. Yesterday, remember we were talking about my heart bullshit? Oh yeah, did you get a new one yesterday?
List Smart List Smart List Smart List Smart List Smart List Smart 我昨天过得很棒。昨天，还记得我们在聊我的心脏那堆破事吗？哦对了，你昨天换了个新的吗？
No, I didn't get a new one, but I went to eat a lunch by myself. I had really bad sushi. Then I went and got, I bought two books and I had an ice cream cone on the way home. I was like, this is it. This is solo? This is by myself.
不，我没换新的，但我一个人去吃了午饭。那寿司真的很难吃。然后我去买了，我买了书，回家路上还吃了个冰淇淋甜筒。我当时就想，就是这样了。这就是独处吗？这就是我一个人。
This is to make your heart better? Yeah, it was. And then I went into the bookstore. Hey, by the way, do bookstores make you want to poop a little bit? Yeah, yeah. You know what I mean? No, I don't.
这是为了让你的心脏好起来吗？是的，确实是。然后我进了书店。嘿，顺便问一下，书店会不会让你有点想上厕所？会，会。你知道我的意思吗？不，我不知道。
There's something about just standing on your feet that long, I think gravity takes over. No, but it's like the coziness of a bookstore, the coziness of like a pharmacy, you know? No? Or like a gift shop. Sorry, coziness? No.
我觉得站那么久，重力作用吧。不，那种感觉就像书店的舒适感，就像药店的舒适感，你懂吗？不懂？或者像礼品店。抱歉，舒适感？不。
Yeah, there was a comparison between a bookstore and a pharmacy. Well yeah, just like the quietness of it and the coziness of it, it really gets my stomach going. This hypochondriac finds pharmacies comforting and cozy. So JB, a bookstore is a place where, okay. Which seems like a perfect segue to go into something we should talk about
是啊，刚才把书店和药店做了个比较。嗯，就是那种安静和舒适的感觉，真的让我的肠胃开始蠕动。这个疑病症患者觉得药店既安慰又舒适。所以JB，书店是一个……好吧。这似乎是一个完美的过渡，引出我们应该聊聊的话题
just for two seconds. Smartless Media is now doing a new show called Clueless. Yes. I've heard about this. Yes, you both were on an episode, actually our first episode. And it's out now. So this is not a podcast
就两秒钟。Smartless Media 现在正在制作一个新节目叫《Clueless》。是的。我听说过这个。是的，你们俩都参加了一集，其实是我们第一集。现在已经上线了。所以这不是一个播客
starring Alicia Silverstone, right? No, that is correct. It stars the host, the host is Elliot Kalin. He's the former head writer of The Daily Show with Jon Stewart, Mystery Science Theater 3000, a bunch of great stuff. He's so funny and I'm the permanent contestant. You're the clue less part of it, he's the clue full part.
由艾丽西亚·希尔维斯通主演，对吧？不，没错。它由主持人主演，主持人是埃利奥特·卡林。他是《乔恩·斯图尔特每日秀》、《神秘科学剧院3000》的前首席编剧，还有很多很棒的作品。他太搞笑了，而我是常驻参赛者。你是那个“无知”的部分，他是“知情”的部分。
That's exactly right, it's like 10 to 12 minute episodes of just puzzle podcasts, and it's super fun. You can- So the little sprints. Yeah, you can try to solve it while you're driving or listening to the show, and it's only 10 minutes, and it's super fun. Will, how long do you take playing Wordle each day, Will?
完全正确，这就像10到12分钟的解谜播客，超级有趣。你可以——所以是小短片。是的，你可以在开车或听节目时尝试解谜，只有10分钟，超级好玩。威尔，你每天玩Wordle要花多久，威尔？
Yeah. What was it like for you to get through Wordle? Pretty quick. Pretty quick. Yeah. Because you usually bust real fast, right? You just guess, guess, guess, guess, I'm out. I sure, I sure don't.
是啊。你玩Wordle是什么感觉？挺快的。挺快的。是啊。因为你通常很快就搞定，对吧？你就是猜，猜，猜，猜，我搞定了。我当然，我当然没有。
Well, I would stack, I would stack my, my Wordle in timing and also success rate against yours any day. No, no, you're definitely smarter than me. Anyway, so Clueless is coming up. It's great. You should listen to it. It takes no longer than, than the average person would take to solve Wordle.
好吧，我随时愿意拿我的Wordle时间和成功率跟你比。不，不，你肯定比我聪明。总之，《Clueless》快要上线了。很棒。你应该听听。它花的时间不会比普通人解Wordle的时间长。
If you're super bright like Will Arnett. I mean. It's fun, it's fun. It's a super fun show. It's super fun games. And it premieres Monday, November 18th. And I'm on every episode. And I play with family and friends.
如果你像威尔·阿内特一样超级聪明的话。我是说。很有趣，很有趣。这是一个超级有趣的节目。游戏超级好玩。它在11月18日星期一首播。我每一集都在。我和家人朋友一起玩。
And you guys were kind enough to do the first episode. It was a lot of fun. Yeah, I liked it a lot. It was a lot of fun. It's all for Smartless Media, which is fun. And that's our little plug. Just check it out bros. Yeah. Yeah. And gals. Hey listen, speaking of checking out, you know what I like to check out? Oh here it comes. Are the films of our guest today. You like? oh. Well, and I don't think that I'm alone because I read somewhere that I think that our guests films
你们很慷慨地参加了第一集。真的很有趣。是的，我很喜欢。真的很有趣。这都是为了Smartless Media，很有意思。这就是我们的广告。去看看吧，兄弟们。是啊。是啊。还有姐妹们。嘿，听着，说到去看看，你知道我喜欢看什么吗？哦，来了。是我们今天嘉宾的电影。你喜欢？哦。好吧，我觉得我不孤单，因为我在某处读到，我想我们的嘉宾的电影
have grossed north of $4 billion worldwide. Wow. That's strong. That's a very strong number. And what's even stronger about it. I hope this person had a nice definition. Well, I wonder if they did. What's even stronger about it is the fact that they're so varied in the types of films they are, and some of them are sort of what you would consider sort of indie type films. Some of them were what you would consider to be sort of comedies.
全球票房收入超过了40亿美元。哇。很强。这是一个非常强劲的数字。更强的是，这些电影的类型非常多样，其中一些是你认为的那种独立电影。有些是你认为的那种喜剧。
Some of them you might consider to be romantic comedies, some you might consider to be just straight up dramas, some would be period pieces. Everything. Everything, and in addition to the financial reward, our guest has also been rewarded with loads of nominations and wins for Sag's and Golden Globes and BAFTA's and Emmy's. Oh, it's the smarty. I mean, this person.
有些你可能认为是浪漫喜剧，有些你可能认为是纯粹的剧情片，有些是古装片。什么都有。什么都有，除了经济回报，我们的嘉宾还获得了大量的提名和奖项，包括演员工会奖、金球奖、英国电影学院奖和艾美奖。哦，是那个聪明人。我是说，这个人。
Or he. He. He's the smarty. He's the smarty. He has been such a part of the film landscape for so long. I know that, I imagine he's embarrassed by my intro, but he shouldn't be because he has done everything He's taught us about love actually he's taught us about what is about a boy
或者他。他。他是那个聪明人。他是那个聪明人。他长期以来一直是电影界的一部分。我知道，我想他会被我的介绍弄得很尴尬，但他不应该尴尬，因为他什么都做过。他教过我们关于《真爱至上》，他教过我们关于《单亲插班生》
He's not at all and now he has a new horror film called heretic you guys it's it's Hugh Grant Only Hugh Grant Look at this guy. Do I take this off now? Yes, take it off. Oh, here he is. Oh, look at this guy. No, no, not the shirt. Not the shirt.
他一点也不，现在他有一部新的恐怖片叫《异教徒》，伙计们，是休·格兰特。只有休·格兰特。看看这家伙。我现在要把这个脱掉吗？是的，脱掉。哦，他在这儿。哦，看看这家伙。不，不，不是衬衫。不是衬衫。
Not the shirt. It's a Silver Fox. Guys, we've got a Silver Fox on today. It is the one and only Hugh Grant. Hugh Grant, welcome to Smartless. It's very nice of you to have. Good morning. Yeah, this is really cool.
不是衬衫。这是个银狐。伙计们，我们今天请到了一位银狐。他就是独一无二的休·格兰特。休·格兰特，欢迎来到《Smartless》。你们能邀请我真是太好了。早上好。是啊，这真的很酷。
I only met you once on the street of New York City, and I said, Hugh Grant. You said, hello. That's it. Wow. In a dismissive... No, you were very nice. Cold kind of way. No, no, no.
我只在纽约街头见过你一次，我说，休·格兰特。你说，你好。就这样。哇。用一种不屑的……不，你当时很友好。冷淡的那种方式。不，不，不。
I'm not a very nice man. Oh, that's not true. We're all the same. That's entirely untrue, I'm sure. So did Sean yell it too loud and everyone then stopped and wanted to take a picture? No, you were... I don't know. I was probably a bit hungover and Did I have a child with me I've got millions
我不是个很友好的人。哦，那不是真的。我们都一样。那完全不真实，我肯定。所以肖恩喊得太大声了，然后每个人都停下来想拍照？不，你当时……我不知道。我可能有点宿醉，而且我带着孩子吗？我有几百万个
Makes me unpleasant Get in line How many kids do you have? Well, we think it's five. Huh? Yeah. But I had to much too old in life. You know, I started when I was 52. And now, you know, I-
让我变得不愉快。排队吧。你有几个孩子？嗯，我们认为是五个。哈？是啊。但我太晚才开始生活了。你知道，我52岁才开始。现在，你知道，我——
Your first kid, you were 52, wow. Yeah, now I'm 64, you know, and the youngest is six. And I need a long stint in a sanatorium or an abbey. I often look at the abbey that Maria lives in in The Sound of Music and wish I lived there. What about one of those old, like really old monasteries that they built at tops of mountains that are accessible by just like a very narrow path?
你的第一个孩子，你52岁，哇。是啊，现在我64岁了，你知道，最小的才六岁。我需要去疗养院或修道院待很长一段时间。我经常看着《音乐之声》里玛丽亚住的那座修道院，希望我也能住在那里。那那种建在山顶上，只能通过一条非常狭窄的小路到达的古老修道院怎么样？
I'm frightened of monks. Okay. I don't mind nuns. Okay. Are you't mind nuns. Are you in Los Angeles right now? I've just arrived last night. Yeah, from? I've come to bang the drum for my film. From London.
我怕僧侣。好吧。我不介意修女。好吧。你现在在洛杉矶吗？我昨晚刚到。是啊，从哪儿来？我来为我的电影宣传。从伦敦。
Yeah? Yeah. How is that flying this way? Is it harder coming this way than it is going the other? It's brutal both ways, I find. I can't do it anymore. I think that's another age thing. I woke up hours ago very, very hungry and it felt like my heart is made of Play-Doh.
是吗？是啊。飞过来怎么样？往这边飞比往那边飞更难吗？我觉得两个方向都很残酷。我再也受不了了。我觉得那是另一个年龄问题。我几小时前醒来，非常非常饿，感觉我的心脏是用橡皮泥做的。
Do you have Play-Doh? Yeah, we have Play-Doh. Yeah, of course. I used to eat it. Sean's got a doctor for you. I've got some upstairs. Hugh, you should know this, that Sean, two, three nights ago,
你有橡皮泥吗？是啊，我们有橡皮泥。是啊，当然。我以前常吃它。肖恩有个医生给你。我楼上有一些。休，你应该知道，肖恩，两三天前，
woke up in the middle of the night with a heart issue, drove himself to Cedars Sinai, didn't wake up his husband, drove himself to Cedars Sinai, they brought the paddles out, they put him under, they paddled him. He drove home, an hour later, he woke up to use the bathroom again,
半夜醒来心脏出了问题，自己开车去了雪松西奈医院，没叫醒他丈夫，自己开车去了雪松西奈，他们拿出了除颤器，让他昏迷，对他进行了电击。他开车回家，一小时后，他醒来又要去洗手间，
and drove himself back to Cedars, and got paddled again. Yeah, and then went to dinner that night. So, you're jet-lagged by comparison. And I'm not saying this to make you feel bad. Well, no, you are. That's working. Yes.
又自己开车回了雪松西奈，又被电击了一次。是啊，然后那天晚上还去吃了晚饭。所以，相比之下，你只是时差反应。我不是为了让你感觉不好才这么说的。好吧，不，你是。那奏效了。是的。
I feel humiliated. But by God, you look fucking great. Yeah, you do. No, I don't. You do, I'm telling you. You do. You've managed to keep it going all this time. You know what I forgot to bring?
我感到羞愧。但天哪，你看起来棒极了。是啊，你确实。不，我没有。你确实，我告诉你。你确实。你一直保持得很好。你知道我忘了带什么吗？
Because I'm a bad packer. Underwear. So I'm talking to you commando this morning. I feel a little bit exciting. I had a stint with that. I went a couple years with that. Let's not go down that, Jason, because we know what happened. I'm not interested in going down it again.
因为我不擅长打包。内衣。所以我今天早上是真空上阵在跟你说话。我觉得有点刺激。我以前有过一段那样的经历。我试过几年。我们别再聊这个了，杰森，因为我们知道发生了什么。我没兴趣再聊这个了。
Well, the details on it are a little sorted, let's be honest. I used to wear boxers in college. I just didn't, I thought, because I was what happened. I'm not interested in going down it again. Well, the details on it are a little sorted, let's be honest. I used to wear boxers in college. I thought because I was supposed to, and I was just like, it's dumb. I don't get boxers. It's useless. That's a miserable experience. They don't provide any worth at all. I like to be cupped.
好吧，细节有点乱，老实说。我大学时常穿平角裤。我只是没，我想，因为我发生了什么。我没兴趣再聊这个了。好吧，细节有点乱，老实说。我大学时常穿平角裤。我想因为我应该穿，我当时就想，这太蠢了。我不明白平角裤。它没用。那是一种痛苦的经历。它们根本没有任何价值。我喜欢被包裹住。
Yeah, exactly. You like to be cupped. That's good. Yeah, he likes to be cupped. And Jay, how do you go now? Do you not wear any undergarments? No, no, no, I'm into the boxer briefs now. It's a semi-semi-semi-cup.
是啊，完全正确。你喜欢被包裹住。那很好。是啊，他喜欢被包裹住。那杰，你现在怎么穿？你不穿内衣吗？不，不，不，我现在穿平角内裤。这是一种半半半包裹。
Yeah, same. I think that's the answer. So, Hugh, we can listen and feel free to say no. We can send somebody over with a variety if you'd like. No, I've already asked a concierge in a hotel to provide some. He looked surprised. I'll go shopping. Hugh Grant, honestly, you know, I do feel, I'm sorry to say you're one of those sort of film stars that I feel like because I've seen you in so many films,
是啊，我也是。我想这就是答案。所以，休，我们可以听听，随时可以说不。如果你愿意，我们可以派人送各种款式过去。不，我已经让酒店的礼宾部提供了一些。他看起来很惊讶。我会去买的。休·格兰特，老实说，你知道，我确实觉得，很抱歉这么说，你是我觉得的那种电影明星，因为我在这么多电影里见过你，
I feel like, oh, yeah, well,'s Hugh Grant, whom I know from earlier. And there is that sort of familiarity that we have through roles. And you have done so many different... And now, I think I'm safe to say, you're doing something that is completely new. Now you're doing this sort of horror film, if you will, for lack of a better word, right? Oh, yeah. I love it.
我觉得，哦，是的，那是休·格兰特，我以前认识。通过角色，我们有一种熟悉感。你演过这么多不同的……现在，我想我可以肯定地说，你正在做一些全新的事情。你现在在演这种恐怖片，如果你愿意的话，找不到更好的词了，对吧？哦，是的。我喜欢。
No, that is correct. We can call it horror, or we can call it psychological thriller. Perhaps for people who are frightened of horror films, like me. We can also call it one of the last remaining viable genres for theatrical distribution. Yes, why is that? Explain that to me. I'll bet you it's because people like to have the scare be a shared experience because a scare at home
不，那完全正确。我们可以叫它恐怖片，或者我们可以叫它心理惊悚片。也许对那些像我一样害怕恐怖片的人来说。我们也可以称之为院线发行中最后剩下的可行类型之一。是的，为什么呢？给我解释一下。我敢打赌是因为人们喜欢把惊吓作为一种共同的体验，因为在家里被吓到
might be a little too scary and being in a big room. That's so true. But you would think that comedy would be the same way. You would. You want the shared experience of the laugh, but comedies have yet to come back. I know, and I sort of brought that up actually to our friend Jason Blum, who makes a lot of
可能太可怕了，而在一个大房间里……那太对了。但你会认为喜剧也是一样的。你会的。你想要那种共同欢笑的体验，但喜剧还没有回归。我知道，我其实向我们的朋友杰森·布鲁姆提过这一点，他制作了很多
horror type films. Blumhouse, yeah. Yeah, Blumhouse. And I said that, JB, I said, well, why don't we make a comedy? And he said, no, there's no money in it. Yeah, I don't get it. Yeah.
恐怖类型的电影。布鲁姆屋，是啊。是啊，布鲁姆屋。我说，JB，我说，为什么我们不拍一部喜剧？他说，不，那没钱赚。是啊，我不明白。是啊，我也不明白。
Yeah, I don't get it either. I understand wanting to be home alone if you're going to be crying, you don't want to cry next to a stranger, but I do like laughing with strangers. I like't get it either. I understand wanting to be home alone if you're going to be crying. You don't want to cry next to a stranger. But I do like laughing with strangers. I like being scared with strangers. Yeah. Yeah.
是啊，我也不明白。我理解如果你要哭的话想一个人待在家里，你不想在陌生人旁边哭，但我确实喜欢和陌生人一起笑。我喜欢……我也不明白。我理解如果你要哭的话想一个人待在家里。你不想在陌生人旁边哭。但我确实喜欢和陌生人一起笑。我喜欢和陌生人一起被吓到。是啊。是啊。
Anyway. Hugh? Hugh comments? It's very sad. No one's sadder than me. My local cinema just closed down after 30, I mean, I've been going there for 30 years. It's been going for 100 years. It's just awful.
总之。休？休有什么评论？这很悲哀。没有人比我更悲哀了。我当地的电影院在30年后关门了，我是说，我去了30年了。它已经开了100年了。这太糟糕了。
Yeah. I would just close down. To me, I can't understand the instinct of someone who says, I think I'll just sit at home and stream. That seems so utterly sad. It is nice to not have to leave the house. I couldn't disagree with you more. My only object in life is to get out of the house. Well, you've got those kids running around making a bunch of noise.
是啊。我只会关门。对我来说，我无法理解那些说“我想我还是坐在家里看流媒体吧”的人的本能。那看起来太悲哀了。不用离开家确实不错。我完全不同意你的看法。我人生唯一的目的就是离开家。好吧，你有那些孩子跑来跑去制造噪音。
Hang on, JB. Hugh, I want to get into this. I'm so glad you're saying this because you're talking to these two, or two people who would... And by the way, a lot of Angelenos who are sort of in the same, our age and who kind of do what we do are equally as boring as these two. No, you're not agoraphobic. You have zero ambition and are way too comfortable in your fucking plush lives and you're not you're not a gore for but you have you have zero ambition and in a way too comfortable in your fucking Plush lives and you're not interested in anything other than yourselves It's entirely true you talk to me a little bit about
等等，JB。休，我想深入聊聊这个。我很高兴你这么说，因为你在跟这两个人说话，或者说两个会……顺便说一下，很多像我们这个年纪、做我们这行的人，很多洛杉矶人也和这两个人一样无聊。不，你不是广场恐惧症。你毫无野心，在你们那该死的奢华生活中过得太舒服了，你们不是广场恐惧症，但你们毫无野心，在你们那该死的奢华生活中过得太舒服了，除了你们自己，你们对任何事情都不感兴趣。这完全是真的。你跟我聊聊
Getting out of the house. What is that you like to do so much? I've always regarded home as hell. I think homes are I've always regarded home as hell. I think homes are hell. The home I grew up in. The fear of the title of a biography. Home, hell, home. The guy who dresses me on films wants my autobiography to be called Coffee in the Custard. And I think that is better actually. Well yeah, homes. I don't get it.
离开家。你到底喜欢做什么？我一直认为家是地狱。我认为家是……我一直认为家是地狱。我认为家是地狱。我长大的那个家。传记标题的恐惧。家，地狱，家。在电影里给我穿衣服的那个人想让我的自传叫《蛋奶糊里的咖啡》。我觉得那个其实更好。好吧，是啊，家。我不明白。
That's why I don't understand why everyone wants to work from home. I cannot imagine anything more dreary or depressing. Hugh, are you currently married? Yeah, I'm married to a terrifying giant Swede. We're going to launch a new podcast from Smartless Media called Telling It Like It Is, starring Hugh Grant. I could, Hugh, this is absolutely delightful and surprising. And obviously we don't, I don't know you.
这就是为什么我不明白为什么每个人都想在家工作。我无法想象还有什么比这更沉闷或令人沮丧的了。休，你现在结婚了吗？是啊，我嫁给了一个可怕的瑞典巨人。我们要从Smartless Media推出一个新播客，叫《实话实说》，由休·格兰特主演。我可以，休，这绝对令人愉快且令人惊讶。显然我们不，我不认识你。
Tell us a little bit about this catch you're married to. This terrifying person who's in your life. Yeah. Well, actually, she's magnificent. Yeah. And... As are the kids. We know you, Jest. Yeah. Now, I should point that out.
跟我们聊聊你娶的这个伴侣。这个出现在你生命中的可怕的人。是啊。嗯，其实，她很壮观。是啊。还有……孩子们也是。我们认识你，杰斯特。是啊。现在，我应该指出这一点。
No, she's great. To my great surprise, while I was being pretty drunk for a few years in London about 13 years ago, the bar I used to hang out at, there was this hot Swede, the other end of the bar, and it was her. She's an athlete, she was very nearly a pro tennis player, but she's just too angry. And anyway, we got closer and closer,
不，她很棒。令我大吃一惊的是，大约13年前，当我在伦敦喝得烂醉如泥的时候，我常去的酒吧里，吧台的另一端有这个火辣的瑞典人，就是她。她是运动员，差点成了职业网球选手，但她太爱生气了。总之，我们越来越亲近，
and then we started breeding, and then we fell in love, and now we're married. But she's very much the man in the family. She comes from the northern part of Sweden. I mean, Swedish men I think are quite masculine anyway, but when they come from the north, where everyone lives among the trees, they're really seriously masculine and men are not supposed to talk.
然后我们开始繁衍，然后我们坠入爱河，现在我们结婚了。但她是家里那个“男人”。她来自瑞典北部。我是说，我觉得瑞典男人本身就挺阳刚的，但当他们来自北方，每个人都住在树林里时，他们真的非常阳刚，男人是不应该说话的。
If you talk, it's a bit girly. So, no, it's true. Her brothers, I've never heard them say a word. For yes and no, they just suck their teeth. They go, that's northern Swedish for yes or no. Oh, look at this. Oh, the food's coming for you. Yeah, I got some coffee, thank God.
如果你说话，那就有点娘娘腔。所以，不，这是真的。她的兄弟们，我从没听他们说过一句话。对于是和否，他们只是吸气。他们发出声音，那是瑞典北部的是或否。哦，看看这个。哦，食物给你送来了。是啊，我喝了点咖啡，谢天谢地。
Yeah, thank you very much. Well, yeah, the Swedes do that. Hugh, if I'm wrong, they do that thing when they talk on the phone, where they go. That's right, yes, yes, that's it. That's a yes, that's an agreeable breath. I've spent some time in Stockholm over the years. I've been there a few times. Yes, yes, that's it. I've spent some time in Stockholm over the years.
是啊，非常感谢。好吧，是啊，瑞典人确实那样。休，如果我错了，他们打电话时会发出那种声音，他们会发出……那是对的，是的，是的，就是那样。那是一个“是”，那是一种赞同的呼吸。这些年来我在斯德哥尔摩待过一段时间。我去过几次。是的，是的，就是那样。这些年来我在斯德哥尔摩待过一段时间。
I've been there a few times and I quite like Sweden. I always say that Sweden is kind of like Canada with much better architecture. The people are really great, but they're also very blunt in that way that a lot of the Nordic people can be. And I was fine, because every time I went there, you know, I'd go and I'd see people, relatives or friends, and they'd say, oh, look at you, you look quite fat. And I'm like, oh. And I'm like, well, it's great to see you too. Mya, you are tired. You are very tired. And I can tell by your face looks terrible. That's absolutely correct. I don't allow my wife to go on any of the group chats with the schools because she offends everyone instantly with remarks exactly like that.
我去过几次，我挺喜欢瑞典的。我总是说瑞典有点像加拿大，但建筑好得多。人们真的很棒，但他们也很直率，就像很多北欧人那样。我没问题，因为每次我去那里，你知道，我会去见亲戚或朋友，他们会说，哦，看看你，你看起来挺胖的。我就想，哦。我就想，好吧，见到你也很高兴。玛雅，你累了。你非常累。我看得出你的脸看起来很糟糕。那完全正确。我不允许我妻子参加学校的任何群聊，因为她会用完全那样的言论立刻冒犯所有人。
Wait, Hugh, did you ever, speaking of the character, how you just described your wife, did you find it difficult to give up control as a man when you met her? Like, before you met her, were you like more in control of, or did you believe you were in control of more, and then when you met her, like before you met her, were you like more in control of, or did you believe you were in control of more? And then when you met her, you're like, yeah, I guess I could hand this off to her, this is fine.
等等，休，你有没有，说到角色，你刚才描述你妻子的方式，你作为一个男人在遇到她时觉得放弃控制权很难吗？就像，在你遇到她之前，你是否更倾向于控制，或者你认为你控制得更多，然后当你遇到她时……就像，在你遇到她之前，你是否更倾向于控制，或者你认为你控制得更多？然后当你遇到她时，你觉得，好吧，我想我可以把这个交给她，这没问题。
I seem to be quite happy in my pussy role. I just can't believe she likes me. I mean, you know, I'm a bit chatty compared to Swedish men. And I, you know, she'm a bit chatty compared to Swedish men. Sure. And I, you know, she catches me watching the sound of music in the afternoons. I love it. We get along great. Yeah. God, I love the visual.
我似乎在我的“小猫”角色里很开心。我简直不敢相信她喜欢我。我是说，你知道，跟瑞典男人比起来我有点话多。而且我，你知道，她……跟瑞典男人比起来我有点话多。当然。而且我，你知道，她抓到我在下午看《音乐之声》。我喜欢它。我们相处得很好。是啊。天哪，我喜欢这个画面。
She also has a long list of things that she says are unshaggable in a man. And they're really tough, like having tea instead of coffee. Yep. Driving an electric car. Yeah, yeah. So far, check, check. For me. Yeah, exactly.
她还有一张长长的清单，列出了她认为男人“不可行”的事情。而且都很苛刻，比如喝茶而不是喝咖啡。是的。开电动车。是啊，是啊。到目前为止，勾选，勾选。对我来说。是啊，完全正确。
I wish I could remember the other ones, they're good. So those are things that deem you ineligible for her pleasure? Yeah, that's correct. So you're a coffee man, full combustion engine. All three children are adopted. Right. So what does she see in you, man?
我真希望我能记得其他的，它们很好。所以那些是让你失去她青睐的事情？是啊，没错。所以你是咖啡男，全内燃机。三个孩子都是领养的。对。所以她到底看上你什么了，伙计？
I know. It's a mystery. And she was married before to a very butch ski champion instructor or something. And now, there was an ugly moment when I was a very champion instructor or something. There was an ugly moment when I was filming this film, Heretic, in Canada, when I went for a walk one day. We were filming in Vancouver.
我知道。这真是个谜。她之前嫁给了一个非常粗犷的滑雪冠军教练什么的。现在，有一个丑陋的时刻，当我在拍摄这部电影《异教徒》时，在加拿大，有一天我去散步。我们在温哥华拍摄。
I went for a walk on Whistler Mountain nearby. And I told my wife on the phone, and there was a bit of a silence. And then it turned out that her ex-husband lives on Whistler Mountain. No way. I'm not very good in nature. And I did get into slight difficulties that day. And I had this nightmare scenario in which her ex-husband rescues me. Yeah. Carries me down the mountain over his shoulder.
我去附近的惠斯勒山散步。我在电话里告诉了我妻子，有一阵沉默。结果发现她的前夫住在惠斯勒山。没门。我不擅长在大自然中活动。那天我确实遇到了一点困难。我做了一个噩梦般的场景，她的前夫救了我。是啊。把我扛在肩上带下山。
That would have been a low point. He rescues you because he lives in the trees. Yeah. Because he's living close to the bone on the land. He's sort of holling logs through waist deep snow. Yeah, well that's him. And we will be right back. And now back to the show.
那将是一个低谷。他救了你，因为他住在树林里。是啊。因为他住在土地上，生活得很艰苦。他有点像在齐腰深的雪中拖着原木。是啊，好吧，那就是他。我们马上回来。现在回到节目。
Hugh, let's go way back. Let's go way back to, so I think for a lot of people, certainly in this country and in Canada as well, I'm going to speak to my fellow Canadians, we sort of came to know you, I think, through Four Weddings and a Funeral was the thing where we went, everybody went, oh, this guy is amazing. But truth be told, it wasn't your first film.
休，让我们追溯到很久以前。让我们追溯到很久以前，所以我想对很多人来说，当然在这个国家和加拿大也是，我要对我的加拿大同胞说，我们算是认识你了，我想，通过《四个婚礼和一个葬礼》，那是我们大家都觉得，哦，这家伙太棒了。但说实话，那不是你的第一部电影。
You'd made quite a few films before, yeah? I had a career before Four Weddings. But it was a bit lame. I specialized in really low quality miniseries. Like Judith Kranz's Till We Meet Again. I was always, for some reason in these miniseries, I was always a champagne baron, an evil champagne baron. I did hundreds of those parts. And I used to sell the family reserves of the best champagne
你在《四个婚礼》之前拍过不少电影，是吧？我在《四个婚礼》之前有职业生涯。但有点蹩脚。我专门演质量很低的迷你剧。比如朱迪丝·克兰兹的《直到我们再次相遇》。我总是，出于某种原因在这些迷你剧中，我总是香槟男爵，一个邪恶的香槟男爵。我演过几百个那种角色。我过去常把家族储备的最好的香槟
to the Nazis and then get horse-swipped out of the house by Michael York. Horse-swipped Out of the House by Michael York. Horsewiped Out of the House. Yes. Another alternate title for the biography. Having raped my half-sister, Courtney Cox. Oh my God. Yes.
卖给纳粹，然后被迈克尔·约克用马鞭赶出家门。被马鞭赶出家门。被马鞭赶出家门。是的。自传的另一个备选标题。在强奸了我的同父异母妹妹考特妮·考克斯之后。天哪。是的。
Jesus Christ. This has taken a turn for the better. And keep going. And? I'd love to see this. There was another one where I was, you know there's a brand of champagne called Chal And keep going. There was another one where I was, you know there's a brand of champagne called Charles Aidsic? Anyway, I was him.
天哪。这变得越来越好了。继续。还有？我很想看看这个。还有另一个，我是，你知道有一种香槟品牌叫查尔斯·海德西克吗？总之，我就是他。
What do you mean? It was not a high point in television history, I don't think. Okay. And I made the mistake of doing a French accent. I didn't have great lines. I remember I had to say things like, you must listen to the champagne. There is laughter in the bubbles. You know, there's lines like that. Oh, God.
什么意思？我不认为那是电视史上光彩的一页。好吧。我犯了个错误，用了法语口音。我的台词不太好。我记得我得说些像“你必须听听香槟。气泡里有笑声”这样的话。你知道，有那样的台词。哦，天哪。
How long have you been a professional actor, earning a paycheck? Yeah, well, 40 years. Wow, isn't that amazing? And before you were earning a paycheck, you were learning, I'm guessing. Was there much training? No, and you can tell. How early did the bug bite you? You can tell. Maybe it was not great training.
你当职业演员、领工资多久了？是啊，嗯，40年了。哇，那不是很神奇吗？在你领工资之前，你在学习，我猜。有经过什么训练吗？不，你看得出来。虫子是什么时候咬你的？你看得出来。也许训练不怎么样。
No, you're fine acting. I never trained. The whole thing started by mistake. I had left university, I was heading off to do another degree in a different subject, which I didn't really want to do that much. Which was what?
不，你演得很好。我从没受过训练。这一切都是误打误撞开始的。我大学毕业了，正准备去攻读另一个学科的学位，但我其实并不太想读那个。是什么？
Well, I was highly pretentious. I'd just done a degree in literature. Thank you. I was off to do a history of art masters. And anyway, in the summer when that was about to happen, someone said, come and watch this amateur film that I had played a small part in while a student at Oxford. And I thought, I might as well.
嗯，我非常自命不凡。我刚拿到了文学学位。谢谢。我正要去读艺术史硕士。总之，在那个夏天，有人说，来看看这部业余电影吧，我在牛津读书时在里面演了个小角色。我想，去看看也无妨。
I was showing BAFTA in Piccadilly that night, and I went there on my bicycle and I watched it. It was not a good film. I was not good in it. But at that time in England, it was very much the vogue for actors to be hoity-toity posh. It was the time of Chariots of Fire, and Brideshead Revisited and things like that. for actors to be hoity-toity posh. It was the time of Chariots of Fire and Brideshead Revisited and things like that. So agents said to me, would you like to be an actor?
那天晚上在皮卡迪利的英国电影学院放映，我骑自行车去了那里，看了它。那不是一部好电影。我在里面演得也不好。但在当时的英国，演员们非常流行那种傲慢的贵族气。那是《烈火战车》和《故园风雨后》之类的时代。所以经纪人对我说，你想当演员吗？
We'd like to represent you. And I said, no, actually, I've got no money. So maybe I should do that for a year. And then I'll go and do my other degree. So I rang them back. I said, yeah, look, I'll do this for a bit. And I got jobs, but I was so bad. I thought, I can't leave it at that. I'll do one more and try and be better.
我们想代理你。我说，不，其实，我没钱。所以也许我应该做一年。然后我就去读我的另一个学位。所以我回电给他们。我说，是啊，听着，我做一会儿。我得到了工作，但我演得太烂了。我想，我不能就这么算了。我再演一部，试着演得更好。
And that has gone on for 40 years. Isn't that interesting? Yeah, because you're English, like we all revere and you just assume that you've had all this training as most, right? Well, I was gonna say, yeah, and there are so many, of course there are so many English actors who work over here and who, as Englishmen
这一演就是40年。那不是很迷人吗？是啊，因为你是英国人，就像我们都崇拜的那样，你只是假设你受过所有这些训练，对吧？嗯，我正想说，是啊，有很多英国演员在这里工作，他们作为英国人
or pose as Americans, but there is always that thing about having gone to drama school, having gone to RADA or whatever. And I wonder if growing up in that environment, now of course you were coming out of Oxford, but growing up in a lot of your peers who are coming out of these schools, was there kind of a, I don't know, was there kind of a... I don't know, was there a thing about that? Was that something that those people... I'm not asking you to speak ill of your friends,
或者假装成美国人，但总有那种去过戏剧学校、去过皇家戏剧艺术学院之类的事情。我想知道在那种环境中成长，当然你当时刚从牛津出来，但在你很多从这些学校出来的同龄人中，有没有一种……我不知道，有没有一种……我不知道，有没有那种事？那些人……我不是让你说你朋友的坏话，
but was there a kind of a thing about that? Were they kind of... Were they lorded that over? Were the ones who'd been to drama school? Yeah. Well, when I did this acting, I was nervous of them, because I thought they must know stuff I don't know. And I did read books about, you know, the voice and the body. And I did tragic drills in the park by myself.
但有没有那种事？他们是不是……他们是不是以此自居？那些去过戏剧学校的人？是啊。嗯，当我做这个表演时，我怕他们，因为我想他们肯定知道我不知道的东西。我确实读过关于，你知道，声音和身体的书。我确实独自在公园里做过悲剧训练。
But no, really awful. Awful. I did one where you had to say, you must run backwards with your arms spread out, shouting, haaaaaa, from your diaphragm. And I was in the theater up in Nottingham, in North of England at the time, and I went to the local park and I did these things. And then I remember looking over at some local kids
但没有，真的很糟糕。糟糕。我做过一个，你必须张开双臂向后跑，大喊，哈——，从你的横膈膜发声。当时我在英格兰北部的诺丁汉剧院，我去了当地的公园做了这些动作。然后我记得看着一些当地的孩子
who were saying, look, he's doing it again, what a wanker. There he goes again. Yeah, in many ways, they were right. Do you remember what the big switch and change was when you went back to do it again and do it better and not be quite as bad an actor as you say you were. Do you remember, did you do anything on purpose
他们说，看，他又在做了，真是个混蛋。他又来了。是啊，在很多方面，他们是对的。你还记得当你回去再做一次，做得更好，不再像你说的那样是个糟糕的演员时，那个巨大的转变和改变是什么吗？你记得吗，你有没有故意做过什么
that pushed you more towards the higher quality performance? Was there one thing? Well, you all know this, it's only about parts. It's just about how good the part is really. And in the end, the script for Weddings and a Funeral came across my desk and I auditioned and they really didn't want me, the guy who wrote it, Richard Curtis,
把你推向更高质量的表演？有一件事吗？嗯，你们都知道，这只关乎角色。真的只关乎角色有多好。最后，《四个婚礼和一个葬礼》的剧本放在了我的桌上，我试镜了，他们真的不想要我，写剧本的那个人，理查德·柯蒂斯，
really didn't want me, he thought I was all wrong. But the man who directed it did and that seemed to help. Although I must say, I never really felt I got that part. You get that feeling, don't you, when you think I'm being rather good, I'm absolutely in character here. I never felt that with that guy. How do you mean?
真的不想要我，他觉得我完全不对。但导演想要，这似乎有帮助。虽然我必须说，我从来没觉得我真正理解那个角色。你有那种感觉，对吧，当你觉得我演得相当好，我完全进入角色了。我从来没在那个人身上感觉到。你什么意思？
How do you mean? I couldn't hear him. I have to hear them, and I couldn't hear him. Well, I couldn't anyway off the page. It helped after I finally met Richard Curtis, who wrote it, who is that guy. And so in some ways I'm just doing an imitation of him in that film. Do you ever sit back? Because I mean, we've all seen so much of your work.
你什么意思？我听不到他的声音。我必须听到他们的声音，但我听不到他的。好吧，我反正从纸面上听不到。在我最终见到写剧本的理查德·柯蒂斯之后，这有帮助，他就是那个人。所以从某种程度上说，我在那部电影里只是在模仿他。你有没有坐下来过？因为我是说，我们都看过你太多的作品了。
Do you absorb how, do you get a moment of how, being proud of yourself and like taking it all in and being like, I mean, you don't seem the type, but like my wish for you is that you accept it, accept all the great work you've done. Well, it's nice of you. I've got better. And that is a mystery.
你有没有吸收过，你有没有那一刻，为自己感到骄傲，就像接受这一切，就像是，我是说，你看起来不像那种人，但我的愿望是你接受它，接受你所做的所有伟大的工作。好吧，你真好。我变好了。那是个谜。
Again, I think it's partly parts. When I got too old and ugly to do romantic comedies and started being off with these weirdo parts, it suited me best. Now you're killing people running down the street. And I have another weird... I have two theories about it. One is I learned really much too late in my career
再说一次，我认为部分原因是角色。当我老到丑到不能再演浪漫喜剧，开始演这些怪胎角色时，它最适合我。现在你正在街上杀人。我还有另一个奇怪的……我有两个理论。一个是我的职业生涯太晚才真正学到
that you have to mean it, that you have to think it. There's a whole other script behind the script, which is all about thoughts and feelings. And prior to that, I'd always just thought, I just need to land this funny line at the right timing. And that's not the way to be good. So meaning it was one thing, but the other thing was, I have a weird theory that it was having children.
你必须走心，你必须去思考。剧本背后还有另一个剧本，全是关于思想和感受的。在此之前，我总是想，我只需要在正确的时机说出这句有趣的台词。那不是演得好的方法。所以走心是一回事，但另一件事是，我有一个奇怪的理论，那就是有了孩子。
I think I was a dried up, middle-aged, golf-addicted Englishman. Then I had children and suddenly I had heart and I had more layers or something. Wait a second, now you're speaking our language. Jason and I are, we're in two hours, we're teeing off. And if you ever are in town and you want to play with us, Hugh, please do.
我想我曾经是一个干枯的、中年的、沉迷高尔夫的英国人。然后我有了孩子，突然间我有了心，我有了更多的层次什么的。等等，现在你在说我们的语言了。杰森和我，我们两小时后就要开球了。如果你在城里，想和我们一起玩，休，请务必加入。
You just said can I come? I just asked. Okay. No, I can't today, but you'll be glad to hear. We need a fourth tomorrow. We need a fourth if you can play tomorrow. So Hugh, talk a little bit about, when you say jokingly, you said too old, too ugly
你刚才说我可以来吗？我刚问了。好吧。不，我今天不行，但你会很高兴听到。我们明天需要第四个人。如果你明天能打，我们需要第四个人。所以休，聊聊，当你开玩笑说你太老、太丑
to do the rom-com parts anymore, but talk a bit about the half serious part of that where your looks still are incredible, but that was a large part of what we knew and loved about you was this incredibly handsome dashing man providing the lead in all of these films, which I'd like to still see you do considering your incredible looks maintaining here.
不能再演浪漫喜剧角色时，聊聊其中半认真的部分，你的外表依然令人难以置信，但那曾是我们认识并喜爱你的很大一部分，这个令人难以置信的英俊、潇洒的男人在所有这些电影中担任主角，考虑到你在这里保持的令人难以置信的外表，我仍然想看你这样做。
But like, was that something that got in your way like some sort of, you know, famously beautiful actresses of our time have often mentioned that, you know, they weren't taken seriously because they were so gorgeous. I mean, you know, was that ever something that you thought, well, you know, I want to be taken seriously as an actor,
但，那是不是某种阻碍你的东西，就像我们这个时代著名的美女演员经常提到的那样，你知道，她们因为太漂亮而不被认真对待。我是说，你知道，那是不是你曾经想过，好吧，你知道，我想作为一个演员被认真对待，
but people are hiring me for my looks. Was that ever something that was a problem? Well, I entirely lost faith that I could do anything else. I believed my critics, really. But I see now maybe I was wrong, because at the very beginning, if I had any talent, it was for doing strange characters and silly voices and things, outlandish things that were nothing like me.
但人们因为我的外表雇佣我。那曾经是个问题吗？嗯，我完全失去了我能做其他事情的信心。我真的相信了我的批评者。但我现在看到也许我错了，因为在最开始，如果我有什么天赋的话，那就是演奇怪的角色、滑稽的声音之类的事情，那些古怪的事情，一点都不像我。
And I had this comedy group that was actually quite successful. The London and Edinburgh sort of fringe circuit, things that were nothing like me. And I had this comedy group that was actually quite successful, the London and Edinburgh sort of fringe circuit, which was all character stuff, you know, silly characters. What kind of year was it? That would be mid-80s. And we used to perform in pubs with people like Mike Myers. He was next on the bill.
我有一个其实相当成功的喜剧团体。伦敦和爱丁堡那种边缘巡回演出，那些一点都不像我。我有一个其实相当成功的喜剧团体，伦敦和爱丁堡那种边缘巡回演出，全是角色表演，你知道，滑稽的角色。那是什么年份？那应该是80年代中期。我们常在酒吧里和迈克·梅尔斯这样的人一起表演。他是下一个出场的。
And that was fun. And actually, just after I made Four Weddings, I shot another film with the same director before Four Weddings was actually released, which was, you know, I was a nicotine-stained, predatory, evil, twisted, unpleasant theater director, and I was pretty good. And I wish that at least I'd kept that other strand of my career going through all those years and years of rom-coms.
那很有趣。其实，就在我拍完《四个婚礼》之后，在《四个婚礼》正式上映前，我又和同一个导演拍了另一部电影，那是，你知道，我是一个沾满尼古丁、掠夺性、邪恶、扭曲、令人不快的戏剧导演，我演得相当好。我真希望我至少在那些年的浪漫喜剧中保持了职业生涯的另一条线。
Not that I, I hasten to add, not that I hate the romantic comedies, I'm proud of them. It's nice to have made films that actually entertain people and they're much harder than people think. And in some cases much better, I think, than the sneerers think. My wife's good on this. She was watching, I think, than the sneers think. My wife's good on this. She was watching, I think, Love Actually the other day, because we like to watch one of my films every night.
我并不是说，我急于补充，并不是说我讨厌浪漫喜剧，我为它们感到骄傲。能拍出真正娱乐大众的电影很好，而且它们比人们想象的要难得多。在某些情况下，我认为比那些嘲笑者认为的要好得多。我妻子在这方面很在行。她当时在看，我想，比那些嘲笑者认为的要好得多。我妻子在这方面很在行。她当时在看，我想，《真爱至上》，因为我们喜欢每晚看一部我的电影。
I make all the children watch it. If they don't watch them, they don't get fed. She said, quite correctly, she said, what's good about this film is that it's about pain. And those, the good romantic comedies I did were really about pain. It's about humor dealing with pain, the pain of being in unrequited love, et cetera.
我让所有的孩子都看。如果他们不看，他们就没饭吃。她说，非常正确，她说，这部电影好在它关于痛苦。那些我演的好浪漫喜剧其实都是关于痛苦的。它是关于用幽默处理痛苦，处理单相思的痛苦等等。
And so do you feel that perhaps, but for the massive success of the more sort of commercial efforts that you made, the rom-com stuff, that you would have maybe had a better chance at being received as a thespian. It's, you know, sometimes, you know, our great directors get stuck in that too, you know?
所以你觉得也许，如果不是因为你所做的更商业化的努力——浪漫喜剧——的巨大成功，你可能更有机会被视为一名演员。你知道，有时，你知道，我们伟大的导演也陷入了那种困境，你知道吗？
They're incredibly sophisticated, but then they direct some big popcorn success, and now they're that director. Where they're shackled by financial success, right? Yeah, exactly. Greed plays a big part in this. Yeah. Greed and laziness. And those two have played a huge part in my career. Well, but you're being falsely modest here.
他们非常老练，但随后他们执导了一些大获成功的爆米花电影，现在他们就成了那种导演。他们被经济上的成功束缚住了，对吧？是的，没错。贪婪在其中起了很大作用。是的。贪婪和懒惰。这两者在我的职业生涯中起了很大的作用。嗯，但你这是在过分谦虚了。
But do you think that... Would you have made different decisions earlier on to balance out more of the output, like chosen some weird characters alongside the idea? Yes, yes, yes. Well, I still had some confidence coming off this other weird film I did before, Four Weddings. And then another one called Restoration,
但你觉得……你早些时候会做出不同的决定来平衡产出吗，比如在构思的同时选择一些奇怪的角色？会，会，会。嗯，在拍完我之前那部奇怪的电影《四个婚礼》之后，我还是有一些信心的。然后是另一部叫《浮华暂借》的电影，
which was not a very successful film with Robert Downey, but I played a kind of freakish cameo in that, and I was pretty good, I thought. And I should have at least kept that going. Well, are you looking forward to now, this stage of, you know, maybe like saying, well, check out what's been under this all this time, and here comes some more interesting parts from you. Well, I suppose that's what I've been doing for the last seven or eight years.
那部电影不太成功，主演是罗伯特·唐尼，但我在里面演了一个怪异的客串角色，我觉得我演得还不错。我至少应该保持那种状态。那么，你现在期待这个阶段吗，你知道，也许可以说，嘿，看看这些年来一直隐藏在这些之下的东西，现在你带来了一些更有趣的角色。嗯，我想这就是我过去七八年来一直在做的事情。
Yeah, I was going to say that. It seems like you've kind of been on that track a little bit, and you've been sort of mixing it up. Yeah, I was going to say that. It seems like you've kind of been on that track a little bit, yeah, and you've been sort of mixing it up. Yeah, I have mixed it up. Yeah, just, I'm so late to the party, but the undoing is a perfect example. You were so great in that with Nicole Kidman, and I loved that series,
是的，我正想说这个。看起来你一直走在那条轨道上，而且你一直在尝试不同的东西。是的，我正想说这个。看起来你一直走在那条轨道上，是的，而且你一直在尝试不同的东西。是的，我确实尝试了不同的东西。是的，只是，我加入得太晚了，但《无所作为》就是一个完美的例子。你在那部剧里和妮可·基德曼搭档得太棒了，我很喜欢那个系列，
because I'm a big fan of thrillers and stuff like that. So that was incredible. I loved that series. Oh, that's nice of you. Yeah, not easy, but very well directed, that thing. and stuff like that. I was going to say, I don't even know what to say, sort of honest, this sort of self appraisal that you're doing and maybe it's because, and I will say, I do share with you,
因为我是惊悚片之类的忠实粉丝。所以那部剧太不可思议了。我很喜欢那个系列。哦，你真是太客气了。是的，不容易，但那部剧导演得非常好。之类的。我正想说，我甚至不知道该说什么，这种诚实，这种你正在做的自我评估，也许是因为，而且我会说，我确实和你感同身受，
as now that I'm north of 50, 54, I spend a lot of time, I don't take as many things as seriously as I used to when I was a young man, certainly when I was a young actor. Certainly my career, I didn't have the career that you did in film. In fact, I always joked that if it wasn't for bad films, I wouldn't have made one. But you seem to have this very sort of healthy, self-deprecating thing. And it's not even self-deprecating. I think it's quite, It's obviously very funny.
因为现在我年过五十，54岁了，我花了很多时间，我不再像年轻时那样把事情看得那么重了，当然在我年轻时做演员的时候更是如此。当然我的职业生涯，我没有你那样的电影生涯。事实上，我总是开玩笑说，如果不是因为烂片，我根本拍不了一部电影。但你似乎有一种非常健康的、自嘲的态度。甚至都不是自嘲。我觉得这相当……这显然非常有趣。
But it's also... I wonder how much of it for you is cathartic to just kind of let it all go and not be serious about it. Is that a conscious decision? I quite like it, and you're encouraging me to do it more about myself. Well, I don't know. I mean, I feel actors can sometimes get a little pious or reverent about what they're doing. And I've never been able to go down that alley. I do in the end think we're in the entertainment business.
但这同时也是……我很好奇，对你来说，把这一切都放下，不那么严肃对待，在多大程度上是一种宣泄？这是一个有意识的决定吗？我挺喜欢的，而且你正在鼓励我多做一些关于我自己的这种事。嗯，我不知道。我的意思是，我觉得演员有时会对他们所做的事情变得有点虔诚或敬畏。而我从来没能走那条路。我最终认为我们是在娱乐行业。
And if you're not entertaining people. What are you doing? What are you doing? It's a bit of a, it's a bit masturbatory. Yeah, I agree, I agree. Sean, you want to speak to that? Yeah, thank you. Yeah.
如果你不能娱乐大众。你在做什么？你在做什么？这有点，这有点自慰性质。是的，我同意，我同意。肖恩，你想谈谈这个吗？是的，谢谢。是的。
Um, no, I totally agree. I always thought that, like, if you, exactly what you just said, like, there's a lane to pick where you make great things that speak to your heart and that are true for you and that you want to make and that's called art and in some form it's all art, but if nobody's watching you make that art,
嗯，不，我完全同意。我一直认为，就像，如果你，就像你刚才说的，有一条路可以选择，你可以制作那些触动你心灵、对你来说是真实的、你想制作的东西，那叫艺术，某种形式上它们都是艺术，但如果没人看你制作的那些艺术，
it's like if a tree falls in the forest, you know, like then what are you doing? But that's not right either. Right. I take back everything I just said. Okay. Because if you don't have the people trying new stuff... No, I know, it's a balancing act.
就像如果森林里有一棵树倒下，你知道，那你在做什么？但那也不对。对。我收回我刚才说的一切。好吧。因为如果你没有那些尝试新事物的人……不，我知道，这是一种平衡。
It's a balancing act. And the problem is, I think under the umbrella of art comes an awful lot of pretentious dross that deserves to die in the forest. That's true. But also some absolute gems and artistry that actually genuinely gets me going. On the plane last night I watched Zone of Interest and you cannot get more incredible filmmaking in every aspect than that film. It's incredible. And that clearly is not made for what you might call
这是一种平衡。问题是，我认为在艺术的旗帜下，有太多自命不凡的垃圾，它们理应在森林里消亡。那是真的。但也有一些绝对的瑰宝和艺术性，确实让我真正动容。昨晚在飞机上我看了《利益区域》，在那部电影的各个方面，你找不到比这更不可思议的电影制作了。太不可思议了。而且那显然不是为了你所说的
entertainment or money, but it's incredible. Sean and Scotty, you guys don't, because it's not part of the MCU, as we'd call it, right? The Marvel Cinematic Universe that we so adore. Sean and his husband can often be found with sort of children's lightsabers battling on the front lawn. Spocky or something.
娱乐或金钱而制作的，但它太不可思议了。肖恩和斯科蒂，你们不，因为它不是我们所说的MCU的一部分，对吧？我们如此崇拜的漫威电影宇宙。肖恩和他的丈夫经常被发现拿着儿童光剑在前草坪上决斗。史波克耳朵什么的。
I like to call it the front lawn. Spock ears on. I like to call it the front lines, but yeah. No, we're big sci-fi fans, but I know what you mean. I think the goals then, if you're making the thing, something like Zone of Interest, and it does find an audience, as it has, I believe, that's the real win, is when you're making- Well, because it's illuminating. It's illuminating, right?
我喜欢称它为前草坪。史波克耳朵戴着。我喜欢称它为前线，但是的。不，我们是科幻迷，但我明白你的意思。我想目标是，如果你在制作像《利益区域》这样的东西，而且它确实找到了观众，正如它所做的那样，我相信，那才是真正的胜利，当你制作——嗯，因为它具有启发性。它具有启发性，对吧？
I mean, not only is it great art, there's also a message, but it's illuminating and exposing people to art. Sometimes, Jason, as you say, making the medicine go down earlier. I hate even calling it medicine because it is, but also getting into conversations about what is art and what is not art is a very slippery slope into douchebaggery.
我的意思是，它不仅是伟大的艺术，还有一种信息，但它具有启发性，让人们接触艺术。有时，杰森，正如你所说，让良药苦口利于病。我甚至讨厌称它为药，因为它确实是，但讨论什么是艺术、什么不是艺术，是非常容易滑向混蛋行为的。
Right, right, right. And I think what sometimes has got lost, or perhaps has got lost, is that it was possible to make big, successful box office films that were smart. I used to have a deal with Castle Rock Pictures, and Rob Reiner, who's the kind of boss of that, always said there are two hundred million dollar movies in this country. One of them's moronic and the other is very bright. And you can make big successful films
对，对，对。而且我认为有时被遗忘的，或者可能被遗忘的是，制作聪明的大型成功票房电影是可能的。我过去和城堡石影业有合作，罗伯·莱纳，那是那里的老板，总是说这个国家有两亿美元的电影。其中一部是白痴电影，另一部是非常聪明的。你可以制作大型成功的电影，
that are intelligent, smart, you know, ground breaking. And he did. Lots of them, you know. And I think it's sad that that's got lost, that that doesn't seem to exist so much anymore. Or maybe it's moved over to Netflix or something. We'll be right back. And now, back to the show.
而且是聪明的、睿智的，你知道，开创性的。他确实做到了。很多这样的电影，你知道。而且我觉得很遗憾，这一点已经丢失了，似乎不再存在了。或者也许它已经转移到Netflix之类的平台上了。我们马上回来。现在，回到节目。
Now, what about Junkets? Now, like the older you get, for my sister Tracy, who doesn't, junket is a press tour for any project you're working on. And you- I bet you that's what Hugh's in town for. Hugh's in town to answer a bunch of questions about this new movie coming out,
现在，关于宣传活动呢？现在，你年纪越大，对于我妹妹特蕾西来说，她不知道，宣传活动就是为你正在参与的任何项目进行的媒体巡回宣传。而且你——我敢打赌这就是休来城里的原因。休来城里是为了回答一堆关于这部即将上映的新电影的问题，
and it's part of the sort of, yeah, you know, bang the drum, light your hair on fire. And say it's great. Not only that, let's discuss the worst part, which is the back-to-back junket days when you sit in a room and then they trot the- They're about to go downstairs and start that. And you do, and they say, okay, so today it's 35,
这是某种，是的，你知道，敲锣打鼓，点燃你的头发。然后说它很棒。不仅如此，让我们讨论最糟糕的部分，那就是背靠背的宣传日，你坐在一个房间里，然后他们带出——他们正要下楼开始那个。而且你确实做了，他们说，好的，所以今天是35个，
and tomorrow it's 41 in a row. And I know you're listening at home and you're saying, hey, fuck you, I stare at a wall all day and then I drive home. But this is equally as mind-numbing, I assure you. Yeah. Yeah, to that point, my question is just like what we were talking about before, the older you get, you kind of have, don't you have the power to say,
明天是连续41个。我知道你在家里听着，你会说，嘿，去你的，我整天盯着墙看，然后开车回家。但我向你保证，这同样令人麻木。是的。是的，说到这一点，我的问题就像我们之前谈到的，你年纪越大，你不是有权力说，
guys, I'm going to do like three today and that's it? Or, I don't know. Yes, you do, I suppose, but you feel a bit of an asshole if you do that. Yeah, I know. Because you've come to love the filmmakers, don't you, to love the filmmakers. You love your, you know, everyone's put themselves out there.
伙计们，我今天只做三个，就这样？或者，我不知道。是的，你有，我想，但如果你那样做，你会觉得自己有点混蛋。是的，我知道。因为你已经开始喜欢那些电影制作人了，不是吗，喜欢那些电影制作人。你喜欢你的，你知道，每个人都付出了努力。
And it's a terrifying moment when you're about to present something to the public. And to just walk away and say, I'm too grand to talk to the media is a bit wanky. Yeah, yeah, for sure. But what happens in the scenario where you've seen the film and you're like, oh boy. Oh, this did not come together. This did not work. Yet you still have to go out and champion it. Is that difficult?
当你准备向公众展示某样东西时，这是一个可怕的时刻。仅仅走开说，我太高贵了，不屑于与媒体交谈，这有点自以为是。是的，是的，当然。但如果你看了电影，觉得，哦天哪。哦，这没拍好。这没成功。但你仍然必须出去支持它。这很难吗？
Well, traditionally at that point I like to get arrested. And then... Yeah. Ah! Brilliant. Then you're kind of out of the loop. Very smart plan. You're N.A.
嗯，传统上在那一刻我喜欢被捕。然后……是的。啊！太棒了。那你就在圈子之外了。非常聪明的计划。你是N.A.
Tech not avail, L.A. But this one, I imagine this one you're excited to talk about. You're in one of those really cool, new, I'd love this new, I guess it's not a new genre, but it's a tilt on the genre of horror films where they've really over the last, what, five or 10 years become much more cinematic. Like these are really, really well-made films.
技术不可用，洛杉矶。但这一部，我想这一部你很兴奋谈论。你参与了那些非常酷的、新的，我喜欢这个新的，我想这不是一个新的类型，但它是恐怖片类型的一种倾斜，在过去，什么，五到十年里，它们变得更加电影化了。就像这些是非常、非常制作精良的电影。
They're beautiful and they're challenging. And I would imagine this is one of those. Did you have a great time doing it? Are you happy with the end product? I am very happy with the end product, and you're right. Well, part of the reason I did it was because it was 824, I'm very happy with the end product, and you're right. Part of the reason I did it was because it was A24, and it's not often in life that you get something as surprising and uplifting
它们很美，而且很有挑战性。我想这就是其中之一。你拍得开心吗？你对最终产品满意吗？我对最终产品非常满意，你是对的。嗯，我参与的部分原因是因为它是A24，我对最终产品非常满意，你是对的。我参与的部分原因是因为它是A24，在生活中，你很少能得到像他们为电影所做的那样令人惊讶和振奋的东西，
as what they've done for cinema with just sheer balls and courage and good taste creating film after film that's fresh and new and often utterly fucking terrifying. I'm still getting over Midsommar. You ever see that film? Yeah, yeah, yeah. No, I want to see that. I haven't seen it.
仅仅凭借纯粹的胆量、勇气和良好的品味，一部接一部地创作出新鲜、新颖且往往极其恐怖的电影。我还在从《仲夏夜惊魂》中恢复过来。你看过那部电影吗？是的，是的，是的。不，我想看那个。我还没看过。
Oh my God. Well, it's kind of like what you said, what Rob Reiner said, you know, like, why can't you have something that is artistically sound but also so enjoyable and so satisfying and delivers so thoroughly that it makes a whole lot of money, sells a bunch of popcorn at the same time. And that's the dream scenario, exactly.
哦，天哪。嗯，这有点像你说的，罗伯·莱纳说的，你知道，就像，为什么你不能拥有既艺术上健全，又如此令人愉快、如此令人满意，并且交付得如此彻底，以至于它赚了很多钱，同时卖掉一堆爆米花的东西呢？那正是梦想的场景，完全正确。
That's the bullseye. Heretic has got that? Well, it's definitely very smart. I mean, it's fascinating. I'm a character who makes a lot of quite long speeches in it about religion. And they were genuinely fascinating to me. These two weirdos who wrote and directed it,
那是靶心。异端有那个吗？嗯，它绝对非常聪明。我的意思是，它很迷人。我是一个在里面发表了很多关于宗教的长篇大论的角色。它们对我来说确实很迷人。这两个写并导演它的怪人，
Scott and Brian, who also wrote, for instance, A Quiet Place, they're interesting guys. They did years of research to come up with the arguments I make in this film. And I think they are really quite startling and fascinating. And so, yeah, I enjoyed all that part of it. And it's filmy. I am obsessed with films being filmy and not just like big format TV.
斯科特和布莱恩，他们也写了，比如《寂静之地》，他们是有趣的家伙。他们做了多年的研究才得出我在电影中提出的论点。而且我认为它们确实非常惊人且迷人。所以，是的，我很享受那部分。而且它很有电影感。我痴迷于电影要有电影感，而不是像大格式电视。
So it's got incredible production design, incredible photography. And it's daring because traditionally, as you know, incredible photography. And it's daring because traditionally, as you know, films tend to try and keep their dialogue quite pithy and short. This is very dialogue heavy. How are you at learning your lines? I start weeks and weeks early and I go for walks every day, going through every single line over and over again because I think they, I have a theory
所以它有令人难以置信的艺术指导，令人难以置信的摄影。而且它很大胆，因为传统上，如你所知，令人难以置信的摄影。而且它很大胆，因为传统上，如你所知，电影倾向于尽量保持对话简洁明了。这部电影对话非常多。你背台词怎么样？我提前几周就开始了，我每天去散步，一遍又一遍地过每一句台词，因为我认为它们，我有一个理论，
that they're like dance steps and that the more you repeat your dance steps, the more you can't forget them on the day. And then on the day you can have other thoughts and other feelings and do what actors are supposed to do. What you don't want to do. Yeah, because it's in your skin, yeah. It's in your skin and I hate seeing in my eyes
它们就像舞步，你重复舞步的次数越多，你在当天就越不会忘记它们。然后在当天你就可以有其他的想法和感受，做演员应该做的事情。你不想做的事情。是的，因为它在你的皮肤里，是的。它在你的皮肤里，我讨厌看到我的眼睛，
or any other actor's eyes, I think he's just looking for his next line there. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Do you record, sorry, go ahead, Sean. As I said, Jason has the opposite. He can look at something and memorize it in five seconds. He's very good at memorizing. I don't understand it, I don't understand it.
或者任何其他演员的眼睛，我想他只是在寻找他的下一句台词。是的，是的，是的。你录音吗，抱歉，继续，肖恩。正如我所说，杰森正好相反。他看一眼就能在五秒钟内记住。他非常擅长记忆。我不明白，我不明白。
It is not that great, but it's sort of a self-preservation thing. I wish I could do what you do, Hugh, but I find the more I do that, the more I sort of nail in a way I'm going to do that line, the more and more I talk about it and rehearse it, then I'm less flexible on the day when I see what the other actor is doing and I actually have to change a little bit. It's harder for me if I'm really nailed down with the lines.
这并不是那么好，但这是一种自我保护。我希望我能做你做的事，休，但我发现我做得越多，我越是钉死我将要说那句台词的方式，我谈论它和排练它的次数越多，我在当天看到其他演员在做什么时就越不灵活，我实际上不得不改变一点。如果我真的把台词钉死了，对我来说就更难了。
You're right. I worked in the theater once with a very good director who used to say, don't nest. You're nesting your lines in rehearsal. You know, and that was brilliant. You don't want to nest, but at the same time, I've worked with actors, as I say, where they're just struggling for their lines the whole time.
你是对的。我曾经在剧院和一个非常好的导演一起工作，他过去常说，不要筑巢。你在排练中筑巢你的台词。你知道，那太棒了。你不想筑巢，但与此同时，我和演员一起工作过，正如我所说，他们一直在为台词挣扎。
That's all that's going on in their eyes. We used to, sort of 20 years ago, when Jason and I were doing a television show called Arrested Development, and we used to constantly be getting rewrites at the last second, and so we'd have our sides with us on set. We'd be looking at them and we'd be blah, blah, blah, and just trying to jam it in, jam it in. They'd be like rolling. Okay, rolling.
他们的眼睛里只有那个。我们过去，大约20年前，当杰森和我正在做一部叫《发展受阻》的电视节目时，我们过去经常在最后一秒得到重写，所以我们在片场带着我们的剧本。我们看着它们，我们就在那儿胡言乱语，只是试图把它塞进去，塞进去。他们会说正在拍摄。好的，正在拍摄。
Here we go, guys. Everybody's up in front of them. We're just in, jam it in. They'd be like rolling, okay, rolling, here we go guys, everybody's up in front of them, just looking, looking, looking. And one of the sets was this living room of this house and we jam our sides between the cushions. So years later, do you remember this, Jay? Years later we went and we did a few more seasons of the show for Netflix, like whatever it was, eight, 10 years later.
我们开始吧，伙计们。每个人都在他们面前。我们只是在，塞进去。他们会说正在拍摄，好的，正在拍摄，我们开始吧伙计们，每个人都在他们面前，只是看着，看着，看着。其中一个场景是这个房子的客厅，我们把剧本塞进垫子之间。所以多年后，你还记得吗，杰伊？多年后我们回去又拍了几季Netflix的节目，不管是什么，八、十年后。
And they had all the old sets. They preserved them somewhere out in, I don't know, in the desert where they keep sets of old television shows and they brought the original stuff. And we sit, we go to rehearse the first day, we're sitting on the couch, and I reach, I think, there's no chance, I reach between the cushions and there are all these sides that had been jammed in
他们保留了所有旧的场景。他们把它们保存在某个地方，我不知道，在沙漠里，他们保存旧电视节目的场景，他们带来了原始的东西。我们坐下，我们去排练第一天，我们坐在沙发上，我伸手，我想，没机会，我伸手在垫子之间，那里有所有那些被塞进去的剧本，
years earlier from the last second jamming them in. Isn't that funny? Yeah. Hey, well, Hugh, you sound like you're a big film fan as far as the way things are shot and designed and whatnot. With all your set experience, have you ever flirted with directing? Is that an interest to you?
几年前从最后一秒塞进去的。那不是很滑稽吗？是的。嘿，好吧，休，听起来你是一个大电影迷，关于拍摄和设计的方式等等。凭借你所有的片场经验，你有没有尝试过导演？这对你有兴趣吗？
It is of interest. There's lots of it which is of interest. The bit that would get me down is... Is the work. Is a year or two years on the same story. I've produced films in the past and by the end of the year and a half, you just think, I don't care anymore,
这很有趣。有很多部分是很有趣的。会让我感到沮丧的部分是……是工作。是花一年或两年时间在同一个故事上。我过去制作过电影，到了一年半结束时，你只会想，我不在乎了，
just get it out. When you're in a Foley session about which footsteps for the postman coming up the stairs. Yeah, true. But Jason, you love that kind of intricacy stuff. Well, he loves the postman approaching. I do, actually, yeah, we're coming up with the sound. What is the sound of a body hitting the ground?
把它弄出来就行了。当你在拟音室里讨论邮递员上楼的脚步声时。是的，真的。但杰森，你喜欢那种复杂的东西。嗯，他喜欢邮递员走近。我确实喜欢，是的，我们正在想出声音。身体撞击地面的声音是什么？
I did that on Ozark once, it was from 40 Stories, and now we've got this other one and this new one where it's just three stories, and it's gonna be a different sound, and I'm gonna try to find that. Yeah, exactly. How did you get the 40 Story one? Did you actually throw someone out?
我在《黑钱胜地》里做过一次，那是从40层楼掉下来的，现在我们有这个其他的，这个新的，只有三层楼，声音会不同，我会试着找到那个。是的，完全正确。你是怎么得到40层楼那个的？你真的把什么东西扔出去了吗？
No, that was something that we thought about doing, actually, like throwing a big bag of something out. But yeah, anyway, it was just louder than the three story one. But I do anticipate that process becoming a bit tiresome. At some point I'm going to gas and I'm going to be like, yeah, you know what, it's just the acting part for a while now. You think so? Perhaps.
不，那是我们考虑过的事情，实际上，比如扔一个大袋子之类的东西出去。但是的，无论如何，它只是比三层楼那个声音大。但我确实预见到那个过程会变得有点乏味。在某个时候我会没油了，我会像，是的，你知道吗，现在暂时只做表演部分。你这么认为吗？也许吧。
It's also very, very hard to see the story I find after a year or a year and a half. To lose your objectivity. Yeah, to produce one of those films, we used to call the cleaning lady in the editing room and just say, come and watch this film. And then suddenly you could see it. You see it through someone else's eyes,
我也发现一年或一年半之后很难看到故事。失去客观性。是的，制作那些电影之一，我们过去常叫剪辑室的清洁工，只是说，来看看这部电影。然后突然你就能看到了。你通过别人的眼睛看到它，
but I couldn't see what other people were. What about writing, Hugh? Have you done any writing or any film writing, any other kind of writing? Well, increasingly, I ginger up my dialogue, not on every film, but on some of them, a lot. It may be up to 80% is scribbled by me. Oh, really? Yeah.
但我看不出别人看到的是什么。写作呢，休？你做过任何写作或电影写作，任何其他类型的写作吗？嗯，越来越多地，我润色我的对话，不是在每部电影上，但在其中一些上，很多。可能高达80%是我乱涂乱画的。哦，真的吗？是的。
That's, there's nothing wrong with that. And then how do you navigate that tricky process of... Not offending anyone. ...ask? Well, yeah, and like, you got to kind of pitch that to the director and or the writer or the other actors and then what if they say, yeah, no, I like it the other way, and then you're like, yeah, but I'm the one talking
那是，那没什么错。然后你如何处理那个棘手的过程……不冒犯任何人。……问？嗯，是的，就像，你得把那个推销给导演和/或编剧或其他演员，然后如果他们说，是的，不，我喜欢另一种方式，然后你会说，是的，但我才是那个说话的人，
and I don't want to sound like an idiot, so here's the better dialogue. I agree. Little window. I'm a master of that particular labyrinth, though. like an idiot, so here's the better dialogue. I agree. It's a little window. I'm a master of that particular labyrinth though. And I also am fully aware that nine times out of 10 when an actor says, I got some ideas, it's going to be shit. And you don't want to hear it.
而且我不想听起来像个白痴，所以这是更好的对话。我同意。小窗口。不过我是那个特定迷宫的大师。像个白痴，所以这是更好的对话。我同意。这是一个小窗口。不过我是那个特定迷宫的大师。而且我也完全意识到，十分之九的时候，当一个演员说，我有一些想法，那通常是垃圾。而且你不想听。
And then you dread it. And then sometimes the director will have to say, now let's do one of yours, just which you know is going to end up on the cutting room floor, just to keep him happy. I imagine, I don't know you, but I imagine that diplomacy is one of your strong suits. You're a flat-out genius at that.
然后你害怕它。然后有时导演不得不说，现在让我们做你的一个，只是你知道这最终会进入剪辑室地板，只是为了让他高兴。我想，我不了解你，但我认为外交是你的强项之一。你是那方面的天才。
Yeah, that comes across roughly. It would help you with directing. It would actually help you with directing, because that's all it is, isn't it? I mean, it's a lot of it. Hugh, when you come to LA, what are the things you look forward to doing? Or as you say, when you just, quote, get out of the house, what are the things you look forward to?
是的，这大致传达出来了。这会对你的导演有帮助。这实际上会对你的导演有帮助，因为这就是全部，不是吗？我的意思是，这很大一部分。休，当你来到洛杉矶时，你期待做些什么？或者正如你所说，当你只是，引用，离开房子时，你期待做些什么？
Well, I was a golf addict for 12 years, so I used to get the guys together and go in golf. In the very old days, in the Judith Krantz, till we meet again days, I used to go to Rancho Park. I bet you never played there. Of course we have. Oh yeah. They used to announce your name through a loudspeaker.
嗯，我做了12年的高尔夫瘾君子，所以我过去常把伙计们聚在一起去打高尔夫。在非常古老的日子里，在朱迪丝·克兰茨，《直到我们再次相遇》的日子里，我过去常去兰乔公园。我敢打赌你从来没在那里玩过。我们当然玩过。哦，是的。他们过去常通过扩音器宣布你的名字。
They still do. They still do. And you team up with three guys you never met. Yeah. More rounds played on that golf course than anywhere in the country. And tell you what, if you like a seven hour round, Rancho is your place. So you've kicked, have you kicked the habit?
他们现在仍然这样做。他们仍然这样做。而且你和三个你从未见过的人组队。是的。在那家高尔夫球场打的轮次比全国任何地方都多。而且我告诉你，如果你喜欢七小时的轮次，兰乔是你的地方。所以你戒掉了，你戒掉这个习惯了吗？
Having kids runs counter to it. Yeah, that killed everything. And also I got the Shanks. Did you? Yeah, I got the Shanks, or the Tom Hanks as we call them in rhyming slang, worse than anybody's ever had them. What are the Shanks? That's when the ball goes far right instead of straight.
有孩子与它背道而驰。是的，那杀死了所有东西。而且我还得了“打薄球”。你得了？是的，我得了“打薄球”，或者我们称之为汤姆·汉克斯，用押韵俚语，比任何人都严重。什么是“打薄球”？那是当球飞向远右而不是直走时。
It's almost impossible to achieve if you try to do it, but it's where the head of the club meets the shaft of the club. So the ball goes humiliatingly. The hosel. You know, there's a very, quite famously, Ian Baker Finch, who won the Open, and is now a broadcaster here in America, a golf broadcaster. And he's, by the way, a very good golf broadcaster, and he still plays what we actually saw him last year playing
如果你试图这样做，几乎是不可能的，但那是球杆头遇到球杆柄的地方。所以球飞得非常丢人。套管。你知道，有一个非常，相当出名，伊恩·贝克·芬奇，他赢得了公开赛，现在是美国的广播员，高尔夫广播员。而且他，顺便说一句，是一个非常好的高尔夫广播员，他仍然打球，我们去年实际上看到他打球，
I mean not professionally. He doesn't play professionally because he won the open He was sort of at the top of the game and he got the shakes Yeah, and he couldn't hit a fairway and he couldn't and it's so thanks for nothing. Yeah Well done. I once lost a I lost a ball Chipping from off the green on live television. I was in a big Pro Am in Scotland. And all I had was the tiniest chip up onto this green, one of those courses in Scotland. Shanked it, went into one of those little streams,
我的意思不是职业地。他不职业地打球，因为他赢得了公开赛，他处于比赛的顶峰，但他得了“打薄球”。是的，他打不到球道，他不能，这真是谢谢什么都没有。是的，做得好。我曾经在现场直播中从果岭外切球时丢了一个球。我在苏格兰参加一个大型职业业余配对赛。我所拥有的只是最微小的切球到这个果岭上，苏格兰的那些球场之一。打薄了，进入了那些小溪流之一，
and was taken out to sea lost. That's probably when I gave up golf. Jason one time at a Pro-Am at Pebble Beach two, three years ago, playing a couple of groups ahead of me, was in a bunker on the third hole and he thinned one, hit it thin out of the bunker and it went straight into the windshield of a car. Oh, that's magnificent. Uh-huh. And I just dove in the bunker and just got outside.
被带到海里丢了。那可能是我放弃高尔夫的时候。杰森有一次在圆石滩的职业业余配对赛，两、三年前，在我前面几组打球，在第三洞的一个沙坑里，他打薄了一个，从沙坑里打薄了，它直接撞到了汽车的挡风玻璃上。哦，那太壮观了。嗯哼。我只是潜入沙坑，然后走出去。
He ducked, walked away, and went to the next hole. That's shameful. I know. Would you like to know my most shameful moment like that? Please. Took my dad and my brother to play golf in northern France and there was one course we wanted to play on, it wasn't open, but they said,
他躲开了，走开了，去了下一个洞。那太可耻了。我知道。你想知道我最可耻的时刻吗？请讲。带我爸爸和我哥哥去法国北部打高尔夫，有一个我们想打的球场，它没开，但他们说，
because we've got our big tournament today, but we will open it especially for you, Mr. Grant, Monsieur Grant. In fact, come early, we'll cook you a special breakfast and we'll take you to the first tee. So long as you get off before the tournament, everything's fine. So we turn up, they cook us a lovely breakfast, they drive us to the first tee. So long as you get off before the tournament, everything's fine. So we turn up, they cook us a lovely breakfast, they drive us to the first tee. Round about the third hole, I'm already in a rage.
因为我们今天有大型锦标赛，但我们会专门为你开放，格兰特先生，格兰特先生。事实上，早点来，我们会为你做一顿特别的早餐，我们会带你去第一个发球台。只要你在锦标赛前离开，一切都好。所以我们到了，他们为我们做了美味的早餐，他们开车送我们去第一个发球台。只要你在锦标赛前离开，一切都好。所以我们到了，他们为我们做了美味的早餐，他们开车送我们去第一个发球台。大约在第三洞，我已经怒不可遏了。
I had terrible golf rage. I've got the shanks with some chip, and through my wedge, as far as I could, over a kind of hill by the side of the third green, I enter the bushes, thought, right, I never want to see that funky thing again. Then realized over that hill was not the bushes, but was in fact the first green.
我有可怕的高尔夫愤怒。我切球时得了“打薄球”，把我的挖起杆扔了，尽可能远，越过第三果岭旁边的一座小山，我进入了灌木丛，想，对，我再也不想看到那个时髦的东西了。然后意识到那座山后面不是灌木丛，实际上是第一个果岭。
And I got over the top of the hill and there is my wedge embedded like a tomahawk in the middle of the green, right next to the hole, and the competition has now started with their best players coming up the green, and the guy who'd cooked us breakfast sitting in a buggy right by the green. No! No! Hello there.
我越过山顶，我的挖起杆像战斧一样插在果岭中间，就在洞旁边，比赛现在已经开始了，他们最好的球员正走上果岭，那个给我们做早餐的家伙正坐在果岭旁边的球车里。不！不！你好啊。
Yeah. Bonjour. Bonjour. Some crazy man stole my wedge and threw it over the scale. I'm so glad I found it. Yeah. Oh, no. Did you ever get to be a single digit? I did. I got to 6.7 at my zenith. Yeah. That's funny. Oh no. Did you ever get to be a single digit? I did, I got to 6.7. That's nice.
是的。你好。你好。某个疯子偷了我的挖起杆，把它扔过了山。我很高兴我找到了它。是的。哦，不。你有没有达到个位数？我达到了。我在巅峰时期达到了6.7。是的。那很有趣。哦，不。你有没有达到个位数？我达到了，我达到了6.7。那很好。
That's nice. Yeah, but you're lower than that. I can tell from your face. No, no, no, no, no. No, no, not at all. I can't play to that at all. Hugh, are you with any of your family, your kids, your wife? Did they travel with you or are you solo?
那很好。是的，但你比那个低。我从你的脸上看得出来。不，不，不，不，不。不，不，一点也不。我根本打不到那个水平。休，你和你的家人，你的孩子，你的妻子在一起吗？他们和你一起旅行，还是你一个人？
No, thank God. Yeah. Actually, my wife is coming out tomorrow. Oh, that's fun. Will you guys go out to eat? Will you guys go out to, like... Yes, yes. We miss...
不，谢天谢地。是的。事实上，我妻子明天要出来。哦，那很有趣。你们会出去吃饭吗？你们会出去，比如……是的，是的。我们错过了……
Concerts? Yeah, no, not concerts. No, we'll go out for... Scandy drinking dinners. And I still have friends here, remarkably. Especially my old Castle Rock friends. Doing golf with them. Oh yeah, oh good.
音乐会？是的，不，不是音乐会。不，我们会出去……斯堪的纳维亚式的饮酒晚餐。而且我在这里还有朋友，非常了不起。特别是我的老城堡石朋友。和他们一起打高尔夫。哦，是的，哦，很好。
Last thing I want to ask you, Hugh, and then we're going to let you go, and I know you're busy and you're exhausted, and this is a drag, but where do you see the next five, because you're making all these changes and doing all these, if you had it your way,
我想问你的最后一件事，休，然后我们要让你走了，我知道你很忙，而且你精疲力竭，这很拖累，但你如何看待接下来的五年，因为你正在做出所有这些改变并做所有这些，如果你按你的方式，
what are the next five years for you, Grant? What would they look like, yeah. Well, the fantasy, which is the same fantasy I've had for 40 years, is that I finally knock it on the head and write my novel, or possibly a wonderful script, but I can't seem to get over that hurdle. I sit down and I get over that hurdle. I sit down and I'm terrified of failure.
接下来的五年对你来说是什么样的，格兰特？它们会是什么样子，是的。嗯，幻想，也就是我40年来一直有的同一个幻想，是我终于把它敲定并写出我的小说，或者可能是一个精彩的剧本，但我似乎无法克服那个障碍。我坐下来，我克服那个障碍。我坐下来，我害怕失败。
But I have pages and pages and pages of ideas and notes. And that would be really nice, because also I think, right, in the last few years it's become less enjoyable to be recognizable in the street. Well, it's just harder now, I find it harder. The camera thing is tough, particularly with children. It would be nice to gently disappear. I would be first in line to read your book. And I would be second in Jason will listen to it. But please do write that book. I think it would...
但我有页数和页数的想法和笔记。那会真的很好，因为我也认为，对，在过去几年里，在街上被认出来变得不那么令人愉快了。嗯，现在只是更难了，我发现更难了。拍照的事情很棘手，特别是对孩子来说。如果能悄悄消失就好了。我会第一个排队读你的书。我会是第二个，杰森会听它的。但请写那本书。我想它会……
I imagine you'd have a lot to say. So... You've been very nice to me, thank you. Yeah, we're a huge fan. Massive fan, man. Massive fan for a long time. Well, I looked at your three names and thought I'm frightened of all three of you
我想你会有很多话要说。所以……你对我很好，谢谢。是的，我们是你的忠实粉丝。巨大的粉丝，伙计。很长一段时间以来的巨大粉丝。嗯，我看了你们三个人的名字，想我被你们三个人吓坏了，
because they're all brilliant. No, no, no. Sorry, you're very sweet. Well, you're... Yeah. I looked at your three names and thought, Plenty more, yeah. Do you do concerts, you know, and you sort of... We did a tour. We did a tour. Really? Yeah, yeah, yeah.
因为你们都很出色。不，不，不。抱歉，你太甜了。嗯，你是……是的。我看了你们三个人的名字，想，还有很多，是的。你们做音乐会吗，你知道，你们……我们做了一次巡演。我们做了一次巡演。真的吗？是的，是的，是的。
And we went to... Actually, we were going to come to London this time last year. We may end up doing a European version of it one of these days. But yeah, we love going out there on the road. If we come to London, and even if we... Would you agree now, and we won't hold you to it, to jump on stage and say hello if we do a show in London? Yes, I'd do that, yes.
我们去了……事实上，我们去年这个时候要来伦敦。我们有一天可能会做一个欧洲版本。但是的，我们喜欢在路上。如果我们来伦敦，即使我们……你现在同意，我们不会强迫你，如果我们在伦敦演出，跳上舞台打个招呼吗？是的，我会那样做，是的。
We'll play golf at Sunningdale. Oh, that'd be great! Oh, Sunningdale, yes. That would be great. Jason and I had said we talked about the London trip, the tour, and we said, we're going to have two dates in London, and then we'll bring our clubs,
我们去桑宁代尔打高尔夫。哦，那太棒了！哦，桑宁代尔，是的。那太棒了。杰森和我谈过伦敦之行，巡演，我们说，我们在伦敦会有两个日期，然后我们会带上我们的球杆，
and then we'll also do a date in Dublin, so we'll play in Ireland as well. We had planned it all. I played in my golf star, which I've told a long, long time ago here, really fast. I played in Dublin with my brother, Kevin, and this is a true, true story. I hit it, I don't know, what's shanked again?
然后我们也会在都柏林做一个日期，所以我们也会在爱尔兰打球。我们都计划好了。我在我的高尔夫明星赛中打过，我很久很久以前在这里说过，真的很快。我和我哥哥凯文在都柏林打过球，这是一个真实的故事。我击球，我不知道，什么是再次“打薄球”？
When you hit it in the brush? It just goes bad. Yeah, so I hit it, I shanked, and it hit a, and I hit it really hard. It hit a tree, bounced off, and smack, hit me in the neck. My own ball. No. Hit me in my own neck. I swear to God.
当你把它打进灌木丛时？它只是变坏了。是的，所以我击球，我打薄了，我击球非常用力。它撞到了一棵树，弹开了，啪，打在我的脖子上。我自己的球。不。打在我自己的脖子上。我向上帝发誓。
Jesus Christ. It was horrible. It was the universe saying, get the fuck out of here. Yeah, and we didn't have, yeah, exactly, and I did. We didn't have a little, what is it called? Card. Card, we just had to walk everywhere. I was like, God, why is this enjoyable? We never play with a cart.
天哪。太可怕了。那是宇宙在说，滚出去。是的，我们没有，是的，完全正确，我确实做了。我们没有一个小，那叫什么？卡片。卡片，我们只是不得不到处走。我当时想，上帝，为什么这很有趣？我们从不带球车玩。
75 mile walk, I don't know. Yeah. It's a nice walk. It's a walk in a garden and you get to play a game at the same time. Yeah, for sure. Hugh, thank you so much. Hugh Grant, continued success, man.
75英里的步行，我不知道。是的。这是一次愉快的散步。这是一次在花园里的散步，你同时还能玩游戏。是的，当然。休，非常感谢。休·格兰特，继续成功，伙计。
I hope you get to do exactly what you want to do. You deserve it, and we deserve to hear about it. And thank you for your time and get some rest. Thank you, sir. It was nice to meet you all. Thank you. It was a pleasure to meet you. And I can't wait for Herodot.
我希望你能做你完全想做的事。你应得的，我们应得听到它。谢谢你的时间，好好休息。谢谢你，先生。很高兴见到你们所有人。谢谢。很高兴见到你。我等不及《异端》了。
Yeah, thanks. Thanks so much. Nice to meet you. All right, good luck with the film. Bye, you. Thanks, you. See you, bye. Bye, pal.
是的，谢谢。非常感谢。很高兴见到你。好的，祝电影好运。再见，休。谢谢，休。再见，再见。再见，伙计。
See you guys. Bye. Wow, is he funny. I love how dry and candid and, you know, refreshing. I know, refreshing. Reminds me, what's that Brian Cox quote? I'm too old, too rich and too famous to give a fuck. Isn't that what he said?
再见，伙计们。哇，他真有趣。我喜欢他那种干练、坦率，而且，你知道，令人耳目一新的感觉。我知道，令人耳目一新。提醒我，布莱恩·考克斯那句名言是什么？我太老、太有钱、太出名了，不在乎了。他不是这么说的吗？
Yeah. Something like that. It was very, very refreshing. I've always been a fan of his, never met him. Never really heard or seen an extended interview with him. So that was really nice. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, really nice. Yeah, yeah. Yeah, me neither.
是的。类似那样。这非常、非常令人耳目一新。我一直是他粉丝，从未见过他。从未真正听过或看过他的长篇采访。所以那真的很好。是的，是的。是的，真的很好。是的，是的。是的，我也是。
Yeah, it's one of those, I don't feel like I know a lot about him. But I love his career trajectories too. Like I love it. Yeah, and he's probably made, he's made like a hundred movies too. Yeah. Yeah. He's made so many movies.
是的，这是其中之一，我觉得我不了解他很多。但我喜欢他的职业轨迹。就像我喜欢它。是的，他可能制作了，他也制作了大约一百部电影。是的。是的。他制作了这么多电影。
And he's made kids movies. Didn't he make, I'm gonna look, God, I should have looked this up, I mean, terrible. He made that, the film, that was, Paddington, right? Yeah, Paddington was a great movie. Great, great fucking movie. Remember that? That was a long time ago.
而且他制作了儿童电影。他没制作，我要看，上帝，我应该查一下这个，我的意思是，太糟糕了。他制作了那个，那部电影，那是，帕丁顿，对吧？是的，帕丁顿是一部伟大的电影。伟大，伟大的他妈的电影。记得那个吗？那是很久以前的事了。
Gosh, I wonder like, you know, back. Bridget Jones, by the way, Bridget Jones. All the Bridget Jones films. Fucking nodding heel, he made all those movies with Richard Curtis that Richard Curtis wrote. Talking about the fact that Richard Curtis did not want him for four weddings, who had written it. And then they went on to work together
天哪，我想知道，你知道，回到过去。布里奇特·琼斯，顺便说一句，布里奇特·琼斯。所有的布里奇特·琼斯电影。他妈的点头，他制作了所有那些理查德·柯蒂斯写的电影。谈到理查德·柯蒂斯不想让他出演《四个婚礼》，是他写的。然后他们继续一起工作
and have like a wonderful working relationship. Yeah. And I wanted to get into that, but he was being too self-deprecating and funny about his life to interrupt him. Yeah, but I've always been a fan of thrillers and stuff like that and and he's got he's got what's it called? Heretic my god heretic. Yeah, I can't wait to get a ticket for that or not get a ticket but bye It's so honestly
并且有像一段美妙的工作关系。是的。我想深入了解那个，但他太自嘲和有趣了，无法打断他。是的，但我一直喜欢惊悚片之类的，而且他有，他有，那叫什么？异端，我的天，异端。是的，我等不及要买票了，或者不是买票，而是再见。这太诚实了
Here's the thing no, here's the thing. No, it's too lazy. Just hang up on him, Sean. It's not clever. It's not clever. It's just lazy. Fucking bye. Smart.
这是怎么回事，不，这是怎么回事。不，这太懒了。直接挂断他，肖恩。这不聪明。这不聪明。这只是懒惰。他妈的再见。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. SmartLess is 100% organic and artisanally handcrafted Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
少。聪明。少。SmartLess是100%有机的，手工制作的Smart。少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。少。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart. Less. Smart.
少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。少。聪明。
Less. Smart. Less. Smart. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
少。聪明。少。聪明。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。